hello well welcome to the I guess the
next presentation and the trigonometry
of modules just to start off a little
bit let's review what we've done so far
in the last couple modules we learned
the definitions or at least I guess we
could call it a partial definition of
the sine the cosine and tangent
functions and the pneumonic we used to
memorize that was sohcahtoa let me write
that down
so Toa and what that told us is let's
say we had a right triangle let me draw
a right triangle whoops
right triangle this is a right angle
here this is the hypotenuse so let me
just write let me label the hypotenuse H
let me label this and let's put this and
say we want to figure out we want to use
this angle right here theta we'll call
this theta whatever then this is the
adjacent side and this is the opposite
side and this that's a No and so so
tells us that sine is equal to opposite
over hypotenuse cosine is equal to
adjacent over hypotenuse and tangent is
equal to opposite over adjacent now that
I think by this point especially if you
did some of the exercises on the Khan
Academy that should be second nature and
should make a lot of sense to you but
this definition using a right triangle
like this actually break down at certain
points I can actually a lot of points
for example what happens as this as this
angle right here approaches 90 degrees
and you can't have two 90-degree angles
in a right triangle can you then it
would it would be like a rectangle or
something but you could actually
possibly figure out what happens as it
approaches 90 degrees but the definition
this definition breaks down for that
also what happens if this angle is
negative or what happens if this angle
is more than 90 degrees or what happens
if it's 800 degrees or you know eight pi
radians not that 808 PI radians are the
same thing but obviously this definition
starts to break down because we couldn't
even draw a right triangle that has has
those properties so now I'm going to
introduce you to a an extension of this
definition it's really the same thing
but it allows
the sine the cosine and the tangent
functions to be defined for angles
greater than or equal to PI over 2 or 90
degrees or less than zero so let's draw
a unit circle so this is just the
coordinate axis and here is a circle of
radius one and let's make as we see let
me make sure I'm using the correct pen
tool okay so let's call this right here
so this is Theta this is an angle right
between this line between kind of the
x-axis and this line I just drew here
and this is a radius right and we said
that this is this has a radius one so
this the length of this line is 1 right
because it just goes from the origin to
the outside of the circle so it has a
radius of 1 and now I'm going to draw a
right triangle again so let me just drop
a line from here so there I have a right
triangle so if we use the old definition
we learned before let's just focus on
sine for now so sine is equal to
opposite over hypotenuse let's apply
that to this right triangle right here
this is the right angle so what's the
opposite angle of this what's the
opposite side from this angle right it's
it is me I'm going to change to yellow
it's this side right this is the
opposite side and what's the hypotenuse
the hypotenuse is just this radius right
and let's just say that this this point
we're two intersects the circle let's
call this point right here let's call
this point X comma Y all right so this
what's the what's the height of this
opposite side what's Y right because
it's just it's just the height of that
point this is of height Y so sine of
this angle right here sine of theta is
going to equal the opposite side which
is this yellow side which is just the
y-coordinate is going to equal Y over
the hypotenuse the hypotenuse is this
pink side here and what's the length of
the hypotenuse what's the radius of this
unit circle so it's 1 and Y divided by 1
well that's just Y so we see that sine
of theta sine of theta is equal to Y
let's do the same thing for cosine of
theta well we know that cosine cosine is
equal to adjacent over hypotenuse well
what's the adjacent side here let me I'm
running out of colors right the adjacent
side is this bottom side right here so
that would equal so if I said I'm
running out of space to cosine cosine of
theta would equal this gray side which
is the adjacent side and what is that
what is this what what is this length
what is the length of the side well it's
just X right if this is the point XY
then this distance here is X and we
already learned this distance or we
already observe that this distance is y
so this distance being just X we know
that the adjacent length is X so we say
cosine theta is equal to x over the
hypotenuse and once again the hypotenuse
is 1 so cosine of theta is equal to X I
know what you're thinking Sal that's
that's very nice and cute cosine of
theta equals x sine theta equals y Y but
how is this really different from what
we were doing before well if I define it
this way now all of a sudden
when the angle becomes let's say 90
degrees let's say this is now I can
actually define what sine of theta is
sine of theta now is just Y is just the
y-coordinate which is 1 if theta is
equal to I'm going to make sure it's
very messy right here if theta is equal
to 90 degrees or PI over 2 radians all
right this is PI over 2 this angle right
here right and similar cosine of PI over
2 is 0 because the x coordinate right
here is 0 let me do it with a couple
more examples I know I'm forgetting the
tangent function and you could probably
figure out now what is the definition
now we could use for the tangent
function
well going back let's use this green
theta here because it's kind of a normal
angle so this green theta here tangent
is opposite over adjacent so tangent now
we can define as Y over X and remember
these y's and x's that we're using are
the point on the unit circle where the
angle that's defined by this by whatever
it where the the radius that is
subtended by this angle or I guess the
arc intersects actually I'm getting
confuse with terminology it's where this
line intersects the circumference the
coordinate of that site the sine of
theta is equal to Y the cosine of theta
is equal to X and the tangent of theta
is equal to Y over X let's do a couple
of examples and and hopefully this will
make a little bit more sense to you let
me try to really fast draw a new unit
circle so let's so that's my unit circle
and here's the coordinate axis was one
of them and here is the other one so
let's get an example like so if we use
the angle let's use the angle PI over 2
right
theta equals PI over 2 well PI over 2 is
right here
right this it's a 90 degree angle if you
wanted to use degrees and now we just
figure out where it intersects the unit
circle I want to again this is a unit
circle so as radius is 1 so we can see
that sine of PI over 2 it equals the
y-coordinate where it intersects the
unit circle so that's just 1 what's
cosine of PI over 2 well it's just the
x-coordinate where you intersect the
unit circle and the x-coordinate here is
0 and what's the tangent of PI over 2
this is interesting
the tangent of PI over 2 well the
tangent we define now as Y over X so the
y-coordinate this is the point 0 1 right
the y-coordinate is 1 so it equals 1
over 0 yep so this is undefined so still
we don't have a tangent function that
can define itself at certain points but
I've in the next module we're actually
going to graph this and you'll see that
it it approaches infinity and similarly
we could try to find the functions for
when theta equals pi right that's like
180 degrees that's this point right here
so sine of Pi
what's the y-coordinate at this point
well this point is negative 1 comma 0 so
the y-coordinate is 0
what's the x-coordinate cosine of pi
that's negative 1 and of course what's
the tangent of pi radians it's Y over X
so it's 0 over negative 1 equals 0
hopefully this makes sense now in the
next module I'll actually graph these
points and you'll see I guess how it all
comes together and and why it is useful
to define the sine the cosine and
tangent functions this way see you soon
bye